okay so we have just seen that if we
have a single recurrent class which is
not periodic then the Markov chain which
is steady state and the steady state
probabilities satisfy the following
system of equations this equations are
central in a study of Markov chains and
they have a name they are called the
balance equations in fact it's worth
looking at them in a somewhat different
way than how we introduce them so far
using a frequency interpretation along
the way it will shed some light on how
or why they are called balance equations
intuitively what can sometimes think of
probabilities as frequencies for example
if we keep tossing a fair coin which has
a priority half of heads then in the
long run half of the time we are going
to see heads
so let us try interpretation of this
kind for PI of J the steady-state
priority of state J imagine the
evolution of a Markov chain as a
particle jumping from state to state and
imagine the observer at a given state to
imagine that you have an observer here
even state J and imagine that this
observer will keep counting every time
the particle visits the state J so you
have this observer keeping track every
time the particle is in state J and keep
recording so for example we might recall
it time to it so it's time for eight
maybe n and you can look at the total
number of time this observer so the
particle being in jail and you can
define it let's call it Y of J of n so
why J of n represent the total number of
ones that you have up to time n so it's
total number so we divide by n to have
the frequency so here that would be the
frequency of time this observer saw the
particle in state J up to time n well
when n is very very large so an odd that
frequency approaches PI of J
in fact we can make it more rigorous by
saying that that converges to PI of G
when n goes to infinity in a rigorous
fashion that we will not discuss here so
we have now a frequentist interpretation
of PI of G now let us think about a
frequency interpretation of transitions
from one to G so again you have a new
observer and this observer look at it
here and every time the virtual pass
here our input a one so for example
maybe one here and here so if you think
about it you're looking at from 1 to J
and of n that would be the total number
of ones that you observe here at time N
and if you divide by n that's the
frequency and so what is this frequency
well let's look at it this way so how
often do we have such a transition well
a fraction PI one of the time the
particle is in state 1 and whenever at
state 1 there is going to be a priority
p1j of going there there might be other
ways to go but out of all the time the
particle in state 1 the frequency of
time it will transition to J will be by
1 J so out of all possible transitions
that can happen the fraction of these
transitions that will happen from 1 to J
will be PI 1 times P 1 J again this is
when n is large and this can be make
more rigorous
now what's the toll frequency of
transitions into state J so these are
transition living these are the
transition of interest here so think
about a third observer looking here and
recording every time the particle go
through here here here over here
so what is the frequency of transition
here well it will be the sum of all the
possible transition that we have
observed there and so this is going to
be this and that corresponds to this now
the last step of the argument is to see
that the particle is in state J if and
only if the last transition was into
stage a and this explained that this
part which we have calculated here will
be the same as this one and that
explained that
so this equation expresses exactly the
statement that we made that's useful
intuition to have and we are going to
see an example later on how it gives us
shortcuts into analyzing Markov chains